so president trump
is deciding to go on the attack this is
probably the strongest evidence yet
that donald trump plans to run for
president again against
joe biden if he's even still in office
and we wonder if that is even possible
but trump just released this early on
a campaign ad
just summing up everything that we've
been seeing for the past few months
america is back highest inflation rate
in the united states
collapse
of covet infections we amplify our power
we summon the new strength this is a
recruitment should we be embarrassed
now the taliban are back kabul is not in
an imminent threat environment the
likelihood there's going to be
the taliban overrunning everything and
owning the whole country is highly
unlikely they own the whole country now
the taliban taliban are now in complete
control of afghanistan
how did president biden get this so
wrong
first of all the mission hasn't failed
yet if this isn't failure
what does failure look like exactly
you destroyed not afghanistan but the
world i don't care
if you think i'm satan reincarnated
do i bear responsibility zero
responsibility china is ready for
friendly relations with the taliban
they're just chanting death to america
call yourself a president
[Music]
devastating devastating and you know i
do love that that voiceover that you
hear there from some protesters you call
yourself a president you should be
ashamed but but other than that
everything else was just
news reports everything else was just
joe biden's own words or those of his
spokesmen
the the only editorial part where one or
two lines there from you're you know
you're a bad president or whatever the
rest
it was him indicting himself
and i don't even just mean to blame
biden biden has no idea what's going on
it's the whole liberal establishment
indicting itself
that that ad is more powerful than just
about any ad i've ever seen in politics
morning in america you know as sort of
ronald reagan touting all of his
accomplishments this was like the the
flip side of that this is what happens
when everything goes
wrong
hey did you like that clip well if you
did please leave me a comment just just
a nice few words just say hey michael i
like that'd be very that'd be pretty
nice of you also head on over to
wherever eh audio podcasts whether
that's apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play head on over type in the
michael knowles show subscribe maybe
leave a five star review and you will
not miss an episode really helps us to
evade some of the
censorship that goes on in certain
places i'm just saying would love if you
would subscribe we'll see you soon
[Music]
you